hi sean really great to be back on
computer file
we are in the lab again i think a few or
maybe about a year ago you were down
here i can't quite recall if the
instrument was running at the time
but what we're actually going to talk
about today is based very much on this
paper i wish i could say it's or a paper
it's not our paper it's by a group
led by this guy alex could turian sorry
alex if i've got your name
for not pronounce your name incorrectly
um at least you're not stuck with
moriarty for a surname
interconnected single atoms could make a
quantum brain and we're going to talk
about this there's an awful lot of
physics we need to get through and sean
hangs his head back
uh in pain the camera's not drooping oh
sorry
we'll try and condense our physics down
last video we did shows on neuromorphic
computing which is about trying to take
the
type of computing that happens in here
rather than the sort of on neumann
architecture which is what happens in
there
and use that to do processing because
there are certain things our brain does
incredibly well
that silicon doesn't do so well and vice
versa when this particular
title popped up in my physics world
institute of physics feed it obviously
repeat my interest directly
they've basically made neurons out of
single atoms
which is really really quite remarkable
not only have they done that
they've got single atom neurons and then
they've also controlled the connections
between those atoms and the way those
atoms talk to each other
so they've also built artificial
synapses
again effectively using single atoms
so this is really quite remarkable we've
got neuromorphic computing
pushed all the way down to the atomic
level and that work
is is based around an instrument called
the scanning tunneling microscope now
we've talked a little bit about this
before i
bored brady harren's ears off over on 60
symbols
about scanning tunneling microscopes
this is a scanning tunneling microscope
all the stainless steel surrounding it
is because it's in
an ultra high vacuum we're manipulating
individual atoms we want to have this
controlled
environment as possible we don't want
lots of contamination we're actually
working with silicon
and if you were to prepare silicon in
air it will oxidize in a
fraction of a fraction of a fraction of
a second
so we have everything in ultra high
vacuum and a pressure comparable to that
you have on the moon
and actually in real time what you're
seeing here these are atomic rows of
silicon
these little holes are where atoms are
are missing
and we along with a number of other
groups have been
embedding machine learning approaches
like convolutional neural nets
and there have been lots and lots of
videos
on computer file about convolutional
neural nets we've also actually had a
number of very helpful conversations
with mike pound who i know many of you
will be familiar with
on taking machine learning ideas
embedding them into the scanning
probe microscope and instead of us
sitting there laboriously preparing that
probe
we're training the instrument using
reinforcement learning and strategies
along those lines
to actually get the tip in a state where
it gets the best possible image
without us having to sit there and
babysit it for
hours days weeks months on end
in a nutshell sharp probe atomically
sharp
you bring it in close to a surface and
when i say close i mean within an atomic
diameter or so
there is a means of doing that 60
symbols
you move it back and forth and you
measure some type of interaction be that
a current
and the tunneling in scanning tunneling
microscope comes from the fact that it's
a quantum mechanical effect called
tunneling that happens on the atomic
scale
[Applause]
or a force and we're now at the point
where you can measure the force
and not just measure but exploit the
force between single atoms
and that's what they've done here
they've imaged and controlled
right down to the single atom level
after that long
introduction we're going to talk about
this particular paper and what i'm going
to do is try and summarize it down to
what the key ideas are
so the paper itself is here
nature nanotechnology an atomic
boltzmann machine capable of self
adaptation
so what's a boltzmann machine well
boltzmann
is an incredibly important physicist
mostly because he thought
about the statistics of physics he
thought about
matter in terms of its component atoms
and the dizzying bewildering array of
gazillions upon gazillions of atoms you
you know try to count up the molecules
in this room
so that makes it a statistical problem
in terms of how those atoms interact
because you know trying to follow the
trajectory of an individual atom or an
individual molecule if you have to do
that for 10 to the 23
some of you might know where that 10 to
the 23 number comes from in terms of a
mole of material if you have to do it
for that number of molle it's an
impossible task
so you think about it in terms of
statistics and that was boltzmann's
genius
was to think about the atomic draw
comparisons between
i'm not sure comparisons raw parallels
between statistics
the atomic nature of matter and also how
energy is distributed
and that's absolutely key his ideas were
soundly rejected by some of the key
figures
in physics at the time particularly
boltzmann was one of the first to
really accept the reality as would wear
of atoms
we've been vindicated long before those
images appeared
in terms of the evidence for atoms but
you know he would be blown away
we're seeing individual atoms on the
screen we're seeing rows of atoms
um there so where does the boltzmann
machine's idea come from the boltzmann
machine
idea is really clever and physicists
really like it because it involves
taking the ideas from
physics in terms of the distribution of
energy
and feeding that into a machine learning
process
in physics you have what we'd call an
energy landscape the simplest possible
energy landscape is think of two hills
with a valley in between we have a ball
it's at the
top of the hill we let go of that ball
what happens it
falls down the hill to get to its lowest
energy state and
actually there are very very few physics
questions that cannot be answered with
well the system wants to reach its
minimum energy state
if you want to use that at dinner party
at some point or in the pub
please feel free to do that pretty well
any question can be answered with that
of course the devil is always in the
details but it's the system wants to get
to its lowest energy or what we call the
ground state
you can think of much more complicated
landscapes energy landscapes with lots
and lots of hills and valleys and it
doesn't just have to be gravitational
potential energy if we're talking about
atoms and molecules for example it'll be
a type of energy that describes how
electrons behave which is very much not
gravitational
energy and so what we do with a
boltzmann machine
is we take that idea of minimizing the
energy
and we couple it across so we draw a
parallel with trying to find the
optimal solution to a problem so we have
a particular energy cost or an
energy gain associated with following
some trajectory or other
and what we're searching for in both
cases is the minimum energy state
or the optimal solution and that's
that's where the boltzmann machine idea
comes from we're
borrowing from ideas from physics and
importing those into machine learning
what we want to do is we want to model
the brain what do physicists do
physicists are very reductionist and for
example
this is a big wet squishy thing with
lots of very strange weird stuff
happening
so what we want to do is reduce down so
the question to ask yourself is what do
we have in the brain
we have neurons and we have synapses
could we
have a neuron which is basically one
atom
so we want something whose state we can
change
so how do you change the state of an
atom though is an atom's an atom
an atom is an atom but what's inside
that atom inside
are the electrons so you can change for
example a really simple ways you could
have a potassium atom
or you could have a potassium ion where
you've added or
subtracted a charge or you can rearrange
how the electrons are organized in that
atom you can change the electronic
configuration leave it neutral
but change the electronic configuration
that's a brilliant question shown
because that's exactly what they've done
in this paper they've changed the state
of the atom
by changing the electronic configuration
now so what we have is the possibility
of having a one or a zero
but also we can flicker back and forth
between those two we can go once it runs
stay in one state go to the zero state
for a little while go to the one states
do the zero state
these are individual cobalt atoms we
don't need to go into
the gory detail of this what we have
here are individual
cobalt atoms what we're imaging here
with our scanning probe microscope is
actually
effectively how the electrons are
distributed so although it's an atom
and you might think of an atom as a
little billiard ball actually what the
stm is sensitive
to is the configuration of the electrons
can you give us a two sentence what's in
an atom for people who
haven't like me have forgotten so
the the traditional model of the atom
two sentences is showing you asking me
for two sentences on the atom
physicists like to reduce
yeah um the typical model of the atom
which is called the bohr model
which is unbelievably wrong but it's
helpfully wrong
is that you've got the nucleus at the
center of the neutrons on the protons
and you've got the electrons spinning
around outside
it's not how it works quantum
mechanically we don't have these
well-defined orbits
but we certainly have that nucleus at
the center and then the best way of
thinking about it is you've got some
distribution of that electronic charge
right which is effectively like a cloud
around that nucleus
what they're doing here by is by using
the tip
and changing the voltage on the tip
they're changing that
that cloud with that electron cloud and
effectively what you're imaging there
is that electron cloud so they basically
have a two-state system they've left to
its own devices it flips back and forth
between zero and one
right so now with about equal
probability our energy landscape in this
case
is like that right so we've basically
got the zero state and the one state
in terms of what the atom is and the
configuration of the atom
is bouncing back and forth between those
two states which is why you're getting
high current low current high current
low counter high current logan and to
use the physicist term it's stochastic
or it's random it's bouncing back and
forth between those two states
and so in one state let's see call this
the zero state
it looks like this in the other state it
looks like this and that's because the
configuration the electrons in the atom
is changing so this is our basic model
of a neuron
right but that's one so when you bring
two of those atoms together
like this what they then find is that
you have a
larger number of different current
values or basic
unit our basic neuron is a single cobalt
atom
and that cobalt atom can be in either a
zero
or a one state we're measuring and
monitoring what state that is
in by looking at how current flows
through
it from the tip that's above it the zero
state we get a low current in the one
state we get a high count it doesn't
matter which way around
we label those now when you bring those
you bring two of those atoms together
they start to
to affect each other they affect the
probabilities
and now you've got instead of having
just two choices you've got two atoms
you've got four choices they can both be
in the zero state
this one can be in the zero state this
can one can be in the one state this can
be in the one state this can be in the
zeros here or it can both be in the one
state
you've got two bits right so effectively
you've got two bits
and indeed that's what they see they now
see that the current
has four distinct levels or a number of
distinct levels yeah four distinct
levels
which is what they've plotted out then
you can add more and you can i
build up the complexity of your system
but physicists
love this idea because it links to
boltzmann and b
it's as reductionist as you get it's
we've broken it down to single atoms
instead all that wet
floppy stuff with gazillions of bloody
atoms widely flopping around in
molecules
we've got an atom on a surface in ultra
high vacuum that we can probe
right down to you know the electronic
configuration that's the type of thing
that physicists love and when that
connects to computing it's
really neat they've even gone a step
further so that's our neurons what
they've then
done is they've basically built in
artificial synapses which is nothing
more than an additional atom and they
bring that additional atom
in and that controls the linkages the
weighting of the link
between those those two neurons
and then they've even gone on further
and they've actually got this thing to
learn to some extent
in that it can detect or remember
the voltage that's been applied to it by
the tip because that changes the
weightings
of the connections between the neurons
it changes the synapses
so that the system can learn about its
previous experiences
and so on we can't do a lot of
interesting things with this image after
just one set of convolutions
but we're getting there so this one is
starting to be transformed
some of them are noisier than others
purity atoms in that sample what happens
in the real sample
is you have a voltage and that generates
an electric